urgent warning from the World Health
Organization for countries reopening
during this pandemic they say moving too
fast could lead to a quote immediate
immediate second peak of illness and
death
Anthony Memorial Day crowds across the
country Gale gave a boost to advocates
pushing for a quick reopening but they
drew concern from medical experts our
lead national correspondent David beg no
joins us from Times Square in New York
David good morning Anthony good morning
a lot of people use Memorial Day to test
the waters literally and figuratively it
appears a majority of Americans followed
the advice of the doctors to wear face
coverings and social distance where you
can but the people who got the most
attention did not this morning all 50
states plus Puerto Rico have relaxed
restrictions in some way or another as
the country now rolls out its new normal
it was the unofficial start to summer
Monday as crowds gathered to celebrate
from the beaches in Taiji Island Georgia
and Hilton Head South Carolina to the
reopening of this casino in Kansas City
Kansas the gatherings have some public
health officials concerned about what is
ahead sure some visitors tried to
socially distance and they wore masks we
try to distance ourselves enough to not
have to wear the MonaVie
but still people still come over he kind
of had to you know turn away from them
many others did not if you're worried
about it say oh if you don't want to
catch it in sale in st. Louis County
Missouri Monday they issued a travel
advisory after videos showed crowded
weekend pool parties at Lake of the
Ozarks officials are now urging those
who ignored protective measures to self
quarantine for two weeks while some were
eager to shake off restrictions for the
weekend protesters in North Carolina and
Illinois called on their governors
Monday to ease restrictions for good
meanwhile in California that state is
focusing attention on kovat 19 outbreaks
at nine Los Angeles area food processing
plants including five meat packing
plants after more than 150 workers
tested positive 25 states reported
increases in their average new kovat 19
cases on Sunday that's compared to two
weeks ago three of them Montana Alaska
and Arkansas were up more than 100
percent dr. Brian Richardson is chairman
of the Cova 19 task force at Jackson
hospital in Montgomery Alabama the
county's cases have almost doubled there
in the past two weeks I'm seeing right
now around 20 to 25% of the hospital is
either filled with patients who are
positive or who are suspicious and
positive the ICU beds are essentially
totally full
Sharon Howell was one of the first
people diagnosed with corona virus in
Alabama's Elmore County the virus
doesn't care where you live and it
doesn't care what your political part is
it can happen to anybody
and we should all be fighting it
together Sharon and her husband both
came down with the corona virus and
they're both recovering well this
morning California has rolled out rules
for religious services to resume it's
got to be a hundred people or less and
Tony worshippers are recommended to wear
masks limit singing and refrain from
shaking hands or hugging
all right well some kind of open is open
enough for a lot of people David thank
you very much